hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skin care
nerd and sunscreen connoisseur
today we're talking about my favorite sunscreens
i made a video about my favorites at the end
of 2019 but then a whole bunch of them were
discontinued in the 2020 sunscreen crisis so
here's an updated version i'm sure some of these
are going to test at a lower spf at some point
so obviously this list is limited by what
i've tried and my personal preferences
i try a lot of sunscreens but i never
quite get through as many as i'd like
because i've only got one face everyone
looks for different things in sunscreen
so don't just assume that what works
for me will work automatically for you
i have oily skin and it's also prone to
acne dehydration and hyperpigmentation
if you want to work out what your skin type
and concerns are and how to choose and use
different products for your skin then check out
my ebook the lab muffin guide to basic skincare
i'm also going to put some honorable mentions
at the end which didn't quite make it onto my
i could happily wear this for the rest
of my life list but they're still great
and they might actually become your favorite
i personally like high uva protection
because uva causes hyperpigmentation
you can check out my video on uva for more
about that so i try to find a high uvapf or
broad spectrum rating if it's australian
i also really like the newer uva filters
they tend to be more photostable and they
give really high protection if a sunscreen
doesn't have these then i'm sorry they can't
join my favorites list that's just the rules
if you want sunscreens that are available in
the us check out my honorable mentions list
the most popular newer uva filters are here along
with their common brand names there are a lot of
different brand names for them now so for example
diethylamino hydroxybenzoyl hexylbenzoate i'm
not saying that again isn't just uvinul a plus
it's also all of these now so i'm just going to
be using dhhb so these are the abbreviations
i'm going to be using i also hate white cast
my skin isn't actually that dark it's sort
of in that light medium nc20 range but still
sometimes some sunscreens make me look like a
mime i also wear makeup so sunscreens need to
not pill up on my skin when i'm applying
foundation on top this is when your skin
starts looking like it's peeling off pilling
depends on skin type some sunscreens that
pill up on me don't pill up on drier
skin so here is my updated 2021 list
i'm going to start with some products that
i haven't really talked about much before
first it's the la roche posay anthelios shaka
fluid this is the version you get in europe and
australia the us version is completely different
it's the reformulated version of the old anthelios
ultra light fluid i really wanted to light the
old formula because the filters were fantastic
and la roche posay have a reputation for making
really high protection sunscreens but i have oily
skin and a lot of really liquidy sunscreens tend
to not dry down on my skin and shift around like
an oil puddle all day this happened with the old
fluid krave beauty ultra violette queen screen
anessa mild milk these formulas tend to do well
if your skin is dry but i hate them they make my
foundation bunch up and go patchy and it comes off
on my fingers all day so i was pretty skeptical
about this new version because when it comes out
of the bottle it looks a lot like the old version
but it actually works completely differently on
my skin it's lightweight it dries down nicely it's
a little bit dewy but not too greasy or sticky it
has no white cast and it's fragrance free it also
doesn't sting my eyes now with icing i think this
varies a lot with different people i've heard some
people blame octocrylene and avobenzone but for
my eyes i don't think it's actually down to the
filters i've tried analyzing the sunscreens i've
had eye sting and no eye sting with and there just
doesn't really seem to be any sort of pattern
there it might be to do with the concentrations
of the filters or the overall formula and
how that travels with my face oil and sweat
mecca recentlyish reformulated their
old to save face superscreen this was
really popular in australia and it was one of my
honorable mentions last time whenever a favorite
gets reformulated i think we all get really
nervous but it turns out this new one's great
it feels and smells and applies pretty much like
the original it's lightweight it sinks in easily
it's moisturizing it has a moderate floral scent
unfortunately i left my tube at my parents place
and so this is the old formula the inactive
ingredients look the same it's just the filters
that have changed and it's been an upgrade the
new version sells itself on being oxybenzone free
now i don't really mind oxybenzone but if
i had to avoid a sunscreen filter it would
probably be oxybenzone and so many sunscreens in
australia have already formulated it out so i get
the decision but the thing that really excited me
was that they added bemt to it this is a newer uva
filter it's really nice and photostable and that's
why it's been bumped up onto my holy grail list
biore uv aqua rich watery essence is the next
one on my list this is the 2019 formula i started
using it when i was trying out a whole bunch of
cult favorite asian products which i reviewed
in a recent video this is really nice and light
it claims to be 80 minutes water resistant from
what i can tell water resistance claims aren't
officially regulated in japan and there are a
whole bunch of different standards around the
world so it's hard to tell exactly how water
resistant this is so for example in australia and
the us water-resistant sunscreens have to re-meet
the labeled spf claim after dunking in water but
in europe they just have to get back to half the
spf so a water resistant sunscreen that's labeled
spf 50 in europe might get downgraded to spf 25
in australia and the us but this is one of the
nicest water resistant sunscreens i've ever tried
in terms of texture it only pills up a little bit
when i put foundation on top there is a generous
sploosh of alcohol in this but it doesn't dry
out my skin and it doesn't sting my eyes the
biggest downside to japanese sunscreens is that
they tend to reformulate after a year or two
which is great from a technology point of
view but sometimes it can be hard to work
out which one you're buying and which one
people are talking about and based on their
history they are due to reformulate this year
so hopefully not before this video comes out
anessa perfect uv sunscreen skincare milk is
another sunscreen i talked about in that cult
asian products video it took me so long to
try this because it's a bit difficult to get
and it's expensive compared to other asian
sunscreens but i've had friends raving to me
about this since like 2012 yeah i am a next
level procrastinator but i finally tried it
and it lives up to the hype again it's 80 minutes
water resistant but i'm not sure to which standard
it's also rubbed sweat and heat resistant it feels
a little bit heavier than the biore's sunscreen
but the lack of pilling really makes up for it
for me and it looks really nice under makeup
here are my favorites from last year which i
still love and haven't been discontinued yet
check out that video for the full reviews
first we have the ultraceuticals ultra uv
protective daily moisturizer spf30
mattifying this is still my ultimate
go-to sunscreen i just have zero problems with
this this is actually the sunscreen that got me
into wearing sunscreen every day the only
issue i guess is that it's only spf 30 so
it's slightly lower protection than a lot of
the other sunscreens i'm talking about but for
everyday wear i'm fine with spf 30 higher spfs
tend to feel heavier and break me out so this
is a compromise i'm willing to make because i
can apply the proper amount without feeling bad
ultra violette supreme screen is a really
lovely lightweight sunscreen that works
really well under makeup as a primer it's
hydrating without being shiny or sticky
like a lot of other hydrating sunscreens
i love that ultra violette sunscreens
were developed by women who have a lot of
experience developing products for women
some brands seem to ignore that women tend
to wear makeup over their sunscreen these
have been tested with tons of foundations and
they don't tend to ball up ever it's also been
recently released as a larger 75 mL version
for only two extra dollars which is awesome
azclear action day moisturizer is what i recommend
to people in real life in australia who want to
start wearing sunscreen every day a lot of the
time they're pretty hesitant because they've
had bad experiences with sunscreens that are
really greasy heavy white smelly and this just
sort of blows their minds i think it's really
good to know of a gateway sunscreen like this
it's cheap it's light it doesn't have a white
cast it doesn't have much of a scent and it's
easily available in chemist warehouse which is
everywhere in sydney so they don't have to wait
for it to arrive and they're not tempted to start
using the chemical exfoliant that i just gave them
without also wearing sunscreen it's a bit tacky on
my skin but that doesn't seem to be a problem for
most people it is spf30 but again these are people
who were not even wearing spf15 to begin with so
this is a win unfortunately from digging around
on the tga registry it looks like a reformulated
version was approved like last week apparently
this is just the sort of thing that happens to
any sunscreen i recommend the new version
doesn't have octinoxate i'm guessing
it's to do with the whole reef-safe
thing i'm hoping it lives up to how
great this one was but i don't know the
formula looks very different and it also
includes mbbt which tends to be a little
bit white on my skin so i guess we'll see
canmake has been reformulated apparently
the new version has worse white cast
this is obviously my curse klairs and purito
sunscreens have been discontinued because they
tested at lower spf i have a video about that
and some of the reasons why sunscreens tend to
test at lower than expected spfs in post market
testing i also recommend watching odile's video
which talks about a loophole that it looks like
some of the contract manufacturers exploited
now onto my honorable mentions these are the
sunscreens that didn't quite make it onto my
personal favorites list they didn't tick
off some of my criteria but they're still
really great and i think they could turn
out to be favorites for a lot of people
some people have actually told
me they are their favorites
my top honorable mention is probably cancer
council's face day wear moisturizer matte
texture-wise this is very similar to the
ultra violette and the mecca sunscreens but
it's a lot cheaper and it doesn't have the
newer uva filters the biggest issue is that
it makes my eyes water but again eye sting is
pretty personal it might be fine for you this
seems to be a similar formula to the natio daily
defence and the ombra daily defence they all have
the same filters at the same percentages and the
nation and cancer council sunscreen seem to have
the same ingredients list the ombra sunscreen
isn't listed on the tga register anymore so i
can't check the ingredients it seems like
aldi aren't planning on bringing this back
anytime soon and even when it was available
it was available for like two weeks every year
this is a bit naughty of me but i wanted to
shout out the cancer council bb cream as well
i love it but it is not technically a sunscreen
this is regulated as a cosmetic in australia
which isn't as strict as other australian
sunscreens which are usually regulated
as drugs but sunscreens in a lot of other
countries are regulated as cosmetics as well
so this seems to be a very similar formula to
the matte moisturizer which is a sunscreen but
it's tinted more but the tint is light enough
that you can apply it in the same amount as
you would with the sunscreen and when i apply
that much it actually makes my skin look really
nice and like a better version of itself
it looks super super natural but it stings
my eyes and i was in such denial about this
that i tried it for a full week after my eyes
started stinging and so i just went around crying
everywhere but having really nice looking skin
so for products like this it might be worth
wearing a different sunscreen around your eyes
my favorite for this is the neutrogena sheer
zinc mineral sunscreen stick this uses zinc
oxide and most people find that this doesn't
sting i generally don't like sunscreen sticks
for the rest of my face because they tend
to feel heavy and clog my pores it's also
difficult to work out how much you're actually
applying so i mostly use this around my eyes
it's water resistant and in general sticks are a
lot more waxy and so they tend not to move around
on your face with oil and sweat as much as
a regular sunscreen lotion i actually rubbed
this into my eye right before filming for
science and it's fine so yay science this
also applies smoothly without chunks breaking
off and it works well for me under eye shadow
now the biggest question i always get is what
about us sunscreens well you don't have the
newer filters so none of them can make my
favorites list but here are some sunscreens
that are available in the us which i really like
these two sunscreens from bondi sands and everyday
humans are australian but unlike a lot of other
australian sunscreens that you can find in the us
they are actually approved and available
in australia the biggest difference between
australian and us sunscreens that really matters
apart from the newer filters is the broad spectrum
label this tells you about uva protection which
i go through in my uva video but very briefly
in the us this means it passes one criteria called
the critical wavelength so at least 10% of the
area under the uv absorption curve has to be at
370 nanometers or higher that means there's going
to be a bit more uva protection but in australia
it's stricter so on top of this there's also the
requirement that uva protection has to be at
least one-third of the labelled spf a lot of
sunscreens that are considered broad spectrum in
the us aren't actually broad spectrum in australia
europe is the same as australia for this instead
of broad spectrum they use the uva circle logo
everyone is obsessed with the bondi sands
sunscreen at the moment it has no white
cast it's a little bit sticky on my skin but it's
fine once i powder over it but it is a lot lighter
than a lot of us sunscreens i've tried it's also
four hours water resistant which is a big bonus
there's a face on a body version and from the
ingredients they look like they're the same
formula but i haven't actually tried a tube that's
labeled face yet to confirm bondi sands are also
releasing a whole bunch of new sunscreens which
i'm excited to try everyday humans is a new brand
for me this is resting beach face it's spf 30
which is great for everyday use is really nice
and light i should also point out that there
are a lot of international brands that are
approved in australia so they also pass australian
standards i think we sometimes forget about this
so this includes sunscreens from like neutrogena
la roche posay banana boat cetaphil nivea avene
so you might already be overlooking some higher
quality sunscreens that meet australian standards
now for some zinc sunscreens i don't hate
i don't think this is a surprise to anyone
but zinc oxide and i do not get along i can
always feel them on my skin they tend to be
thick and clog up my pores and mess up my fringe
sometimes they dehydrate my skin and make it go
flaky while also feeling greasy which is like top
10 skincare betrayals there's usually white cast
they just don't spark joy but i found a few that i
actually quite like and this is a new and exciting
experience for me it's ultra violette lean screen
paula's choice super light daily wrinkle defense
and naked sundays collagen glow mineral sunscreen
i think a lot of brands have caught on to the fact
that if you put a bit of tint into a zinc oxide
sunscreen then it reduces white cast even if
that tint doesn't necessarily match people's
skin tone all three of these are pretty much
invisible on my skin even though they all look
like different colors coming out of the tube but
i've still seen people with darker skin complain
about white cast from the ultraviolet and the
paula's choice i expect it'll be the same for the
naked sundays since it's even lighter in tint than
the other two paula's choice isn't actually
approved in australia as a proper sunscreen
but it is really nice and light in texture which
is amazing for a zinc oxide sunscreen the other
two are spf 50 plus which means they have more
than double the protection yeah spf 50 plus means
spf 60 or higher in australia things work
differently here there was like a whole emu war
anyway these two are a fair bit thicker
in texture they're a little bit like paste
i have to powder quite thickly on top to make
sure my fringe doesn't stick down on them but
if i had to wear a really high protection zinc
oxide sunscreen it would be one of these two
this is the face version of evy sunscreen evy
are a swedish brand and they use the special
technology that gets the sunscreen into the top
layers of skin so it doesn't rub off easily it's
very cool i've talked about the data that backs
up their claims before but this felt a little
bit sticky and uncomfortable on my face apparently
with swedish customers this is considered really
light and comfortable it might be because i've
been spoilt with these light asian and australian
sunscreens or it might be because it's so humid
in sydney i still use evy a lot on my body though
so that is it those are my favorites
let me know if you've tried any of these
and what you thought or if you have sunscreens
that you recommend that i haven't mentioned before
like subscribe and follow let me know what other
categories of products you want me to go through
my favorites of next time there is probably a
50/50 chance i'll be talking about sunscreen again